hi this is Peter Russell of university
of story
I am a story doctor in Hollywood I also
teach at UCLA and Pepperdine but in my
own school University of story you can
find what I'm talking about today what
I'm talking about today is television
because the television market is insane
right now I tell my students you are and
the luckiest people in the world to be
working in entertainment today because
there are so many hungry mouths in the
television world there is the network
there is the cable there is the internet
platform we've gone from 200 scripted
shows every year to over 400 in just
five years
so you're an insanely golden age of
television so we're gonna talk about TV
you know 80% of my business five years
ago was movies and I still do story
doctoring for movies but 80% of my
business now as a story doctor is for
television why is this well television
is different from movies but all the
patterns and secrets that I learned in
my career as a story doctor for movies
work in television and we're gonna see
that in a brilliant brilliant story
pilot of Breaking Bad tonight I want to
break down the pilot episode of Breaking
Bad probably in a way you've never seen
so you understand if you're writing an
hour drama just how its structured and
what the brilliance of this story is now
Breaking Bad is let's logline Breaking
Bad know a logline
in movies is a statement of how a hero
changes and heals but in a television
show a logline is different in the
television show a log on is simply the
heroes goals and the obstacles in his
way
what's the difference between these two
it's really critical in a movie you're
watching because you want to see the
hero change he can either get worse if
he can get better but he's changing he's
either healing a ripping open a core
wound in television a hero doesn't
change everything changes but the
characters in TV but what does change is
the character reveals new aspects of
himself and we're gonna see in Breaking
Bad today
that the hero in Breaking Bad's pilot
reveals new aspects of himself I also
want to tell you that in the television
pilot it's the only time in television
that you hero can change by the end of
this pilot Walter White has become what
he's gonna pretty much be for the next
seven years a drug-dealing murderer
he's gonna change marginally from
knowing out but his big change happens
in the pilot so what is that well I
always want to ask several questions
when we create a television show and
these are questions you should ask
yourself about your own show first of
all your logline is critical let me give
you the logline for Breaking Bad a high
school chemistry teacher dying of cancer
teams with a former student to
manufacture and sell crystal meth to
secure his family's future now that's
not a movie long line in a movie log
line you'd want to know what happened to
him right what happens does he do it
does he not does he heal does he stop
being a meth dealer no not in television
television is simply about goals and the
obstacles in the way because remember
we're telling a story that takes place
over a hundred to a hundred and fifty
episodes quite different from movies
although the same rules are used this is
a thriller and all my movie thriller
rules that I should give you in
university of stories thriller lecture
for movies also work in television I
have a television lecture at university
of story calm as well
what is this logline mean well when
you're recreating a television show
actually the creator of this television
show is brilliant Vince Gilligan was
actually he says sitting around
unemployed he's not at his idea he was
talking to his collaborator and he said
you know what we're broke we need money
maybe we should sell drugs and from that
kernel of an idea they started breaking
this log line now there's eight
questions I love to ask in television
one is what's the world of your show the
world of this show is Albuquerque New
Mexico now how the hell is that
interesting I'll tell you why because
it's literally
Albuquerque they shot it there and if
you know Hollywood you know that when
they make a middle class world they
usually put it up on a set in Riverside
and it's carpenter and it looks like
every other set you've ever seen but if
you actually shoot in the place you are
telling about you have a huge advantage
the French call it cinema verite we just
call it hey we got the budget to go on
location but it's the same thing because
it's real you really see the real
middle-class world of Albuquerque and
it's cool because it's so not cool
yes what's the premise here well what is
a premise in television it's a guy who's
gonna be selling drugs what's the
setting Albuquerque what's the theme
well I'll tell you a theme in television
is really important it's not like in
high school English where your teacher
asks you what's the theme of Julius
Caesar and you threw a spitball at her
the theme here is power corrupts and
absolute power crops and my father used
to say never corner a weak man you will
regret it Walter White is a weak guy
given power and we see what that does to
him it's a great theme the next thing we
ask in televisions what's the hook why
do we want to come back for 150 episodes
we don't need to do that in a movie but
we do in television what is the hook
here well what do you think the hook is
watching Walter White go from
mild-mannered geek to a drug-dealing
murderer
how far is Walter gonna go that's a
great question we're gonna I see it
every week the next thing is a genre
which is thriller we're gonna talk about
that as we go through this pilot episode
I'm gonna break it all down for you
you're gonna be using these hidden
patterns when you're writing your
television show matter what our John
root is there's 25 television John Rizzo
their own patterns if you don't know
them you're gonna get lost the next
thing is the character situation two
questions are going to keep us watching
for seven years what is the question
here well it's an unresolvable conflict
our dilemma now what do I mean by that
you don't need it in movies you have to
have it in TV what's an unresolvable
dilemma it is a question that will never
be satisfactorily answered okay
in Walters case it's this Walter wants
to save his family that's why he becomes
a drug dealer to make money but in doing
that he destroys his family
that's unresolvable it's called irony by
hipsters they must use it but
unresolvable dilemmas keep you coming
back to a television show you don't need
it in movies what's the unresolvable
conflict in say Mad Men Don Draper is a
traditionalist family man who was a big
great provider he's also a completely
amoral marriage wrecker unresolvable
dilemma will watch him for a hundred
episodes and he never resolves it yes
what's the unresolvable dilemma in Game
of Thrones
it's this how can good people prevail as
leaders when power corrupts absolutely
how come
good people never can become in charge
around the world you see crappy leaders
why what we're thirsting for is a good
leader but the very qualities that make
you a leader can preclude you from being
a good one so what's your story the next
thing we need are characters who
surprised us in television you must be
surprised
remember characters don't change they
just surprised when Janice shoots Richie
in that great episode of The Sopranos
and she kills him right there at the
dinner table with a pistol were shocked
were surprised were titillated do we
think Janice has changed no has Richie
changed well he's dead but no he's not
gonna change anymore he's dead but they
both surprised us Richie surprises by
hitting her for the first time she
surprises us by killing him with a
pistol big surprise this is how
television works finally what is a
character's superpower at the beginning
of a television pilot they are misusing
it Don Draper's misusing a seductive
abilities at the beginning of the first
episode of Mad Men tearing Lannister's
misusing his abilities at the first
episode of Game of Thrones
what is Walter White doing and breaking
he's misusing his genius for chemistry
he's misusing his genius for being
incredibly smart he's wasting his life
as a really bad high school teacher
doing nothing else he's gonna be using
really malevolent way but boy is he
using it the next thing you need are
structure and dog we're gonna do talk
about that as we go along now by the way
guys just one other thing about theme
what do you want to say in your story do
you just want a house in Malibu is that
why you're writing your television show
because if that's the only reason you're
writing it maybe you'll succeed but it
won't be a very strong story why is that
what's the truth about life you want to
get across in your story there is a
truth about life and breaking bad what
do you want to say about life this isn't
just some stupid exercise it's your
passion because remember theme is about
the truth you want to tell about life
what do you want to say what do you want
to say nothing we'll think about it you
do want to say something Vince Gilligan
is saying that power really corrupts
absolutely corrupts especially weak
people what's the theme in oranges a new
bot by the way a great show by Jenji
Kohan what's the theme there what's the
problem in that show
it's that Piper doesn't have a strong
sense of herself that means she can go
with girls she can go with guys she can
betray them both she doesn't know who
she is
you gotta know who you are that's a
great theme too in Sons of Anarchy
another fabulous show the hero wants or
I'd the writer this show Kurt Sutter
wants to tell us you're doomed if you
don't have a good mentor do you not have
a good mentor have you not had a good
mentor in your life are your parents
shitty a crappy sorry if they're crappy
you're in trouble you better find a
mentor that's the whole reason Kurt
Sutter wrote Sons of Anarchy even if he
tells it wasn't so we need to understand
the theme in this show because it's an
every page of the show so what do you
really believe what are you passionate
about now what's the hook in this show
well we already know that so I want to
start walking through this story to see
the hook
you ever seen a show called men on the
high castle what's the hook there will
our protagonist succeed in throwing off
Japan and Germany from America making a
murderer what's the hook there will the
villains max managed to frame this guy
for murder twice orange is the new black
will piper ever figure out his sexuality
Breaking Bad it's how far is Walter
gonna go you can see that in this pilot
it's really really important right so
let's take a look at it and what I
suggest you do is you pull up this pilot
both as a script and as a television
episode and you study it as we go along
and as you do that I'm gonna be breaking
it down so I'll give you a chance now to
buy that class buy that movie from
Amazon there's literally dozens of ways
to get this and then we're gonna do that
we're gonna look at both of those things
so let's start out with Breaking Bad and
as we start out what do we start out
with we started with a cold open cold
open is just the first five minutes of a
show no titles just write into the show
and structurally we have the first and
the second most important story line in
the entire pilot posed in this cold open
now what is a story line question it is
the central question of your story
what's your story line about what's your
movie about what's your movie
what should television show about what
if you had to ask yourself what is my
television show about what would you say
what would your logline be think of it
right now I bet you have some trouble
doing that you get well it's about it's
about a girl who's an albino and she is
being chased oh wait a minute hang on no
it's about the corruption of a society
wait a minute no it's about so guys I
urge you to try to log line your story
what is the most important part of your
television show what is the question you
want to see answered in the pilot and
maybe throughout the entire seasons run
of your show okay what is it in mad
minutes we'll Don Draper succeed in not
being a villainous adulterer in his
private life will he let his commercials
says heal him yes that's the a storyline
for the pilot and it's the a storyline
for the entire run of the show for Game
of Thrones the a story log line is which
family will win because we need to unite
everyone in order to fight the White
Walkers that's the a story long line and
it's for the pilot and it's the a story
log line for the entire run of the show
yes all seven or ten or fifteen years
whatever it's going to be so you need to
have in an hour drama at least four
different story lines we call them the
ABCD sometimes you have six more gingy
Cohan and in oranges a new black can
handle 12 but these four story lines
alternate in a very particular pattern
and you need to go to my lecture some
other lecture on university of story I
have a television lecture that shows you
how these four story lines alternate in
all hour-long dramas no matter how cool
you are no matter what a hipster you are
David Lynch has to use these patterns
probably unwillingly but every great
creator uses these same patterns of
story why because it's a way to
entertain the audience television is
more complex than movies we need to have
more storylines than we do in a movie
movies usually have only two storylines
television can have up to 10 and an hour
drama alternates them in each act in a
very specific way I'm gonna show you how
that's done in Breaking Bad the a
storyline in Breaking Bad I'm just gonna
tell you right now is this will Walter
White become a badass drug dealer that's
it that's the a question and by the way
if you have a for act chart box which
every television production company uses
there may be five writers like four
producers like six because they can sell
more commercials you will have seven
little boxes and each one of those boxes
is a beat and there are seven in the
first act 7 in the second act seven in
the third and seven in the fourth
because you have 28 beats in an hour
drama and the a storyline takes up from
14 to 16 of those little boxes the B
story takes up to 6
in those little boxes maybe eight the C
takes up three or four and the D can
take up two or three why because the a
storyline is the most important and we
often open and close our acts on our a
story let's now guys I know this sounds
complex you can learn it in my lecture
you can learn it somewhere else you
better learn it because that's how
pilots are written so we open up in the
cold open of Breaking Bad with this RV
racing through the desert with this
middle-aged guy wearing nothing but
baggy underwear and Costco glasses on a
gas mask why by the way are we riveted
by this it's nothing particularly
interesting it's because we're seeing
that he drives badly and he almost
crashes over and over again that's
called good news bad news and a ticking
clock is he gonna crash
and these suspense techniques are used
in every single television show and
every single movie that's any good ever
Hitchcock invented a lot of them I just
saw North by Northwest for the first
time you know they're not I'm sorry I
should have seen it years ago and he
uses these techniques in every scene so
Gilligan does to this RV finally crashes
but as it does we're seeing Walter White
in these baggy pants jumping out of the
RV know what's riveting about this guy
he's dressed in cheap clothes and he's
not in good shape and he's wearing BVDs
that cost $3 why are we interested in
him because he's real an actor given
this role would have worked out for six
months gotten really great abs and lats
and jumped out of the RV hey Here I am
Walter isn't every man and he's got two
bodies in his car and a guy behind the
passenger seat with a gas mask on he
climbs out of the RV he puts his pants
off he grieves his pants and then we
hear what a siren there's a siren the
siren is a ticking clock the cops are
coming
so the a story line is will Walter
become a badass drug dealer what's in
the RV two bodies a bunch of chemicals
but now he grabs a video camera and he
tearfully records a farewell to his
family and as he does he says this is
not for the police I'm speaking to my
family now
that is the B storyline remember the a
and the B storyline alternate in the
cold open the B story line here is will
Walt take care of his family and by
speaking to this camera it looks like
he's doing just that and what does he
say I love you
there are things people are gonna tell
me I tell you about me they're wrong I'm
not a criminal I wanted to take care of
you that's the B storyline then the
sirens get louder
Walter takes a gun from his underwear
steps up to the road points the pistol
right at the at the road and stands
there why the siren gets loud boom end
of cold-open
that's a great cliffhanger and it's a
ticking clock and it doesn't get
resolved and we go to the credits so
what have we seen in the cold open a
story B story back to a story that's a
great open now guys in act 1 where do we
go to a middle class house at 5:00 a.m.
and a loser because Walt's in bed with
his wife in a terrible shabby little
vinyl papered bedroom but it's not poor
guys Hollywood usually Hollywood shows
poor people really well they show rich
people really well what they have
trouble with are showing middle class
people as they really live Walter and
his wife Skyler are unsuccessful but
they're not poor Walt sighs he wakes up
he throws off the cover his pajamas are
clean but they're synthetic and cheap he
exercises on this little Stairmaster
that's broken he doesn't give us crap
about his life and now suddenly we see
on the wall in this really looser place
a plaque that says in 1985 nuclear
chemistry what does that tell us
remember I said that a hero is misusing
his super power at the beginning of the
story how is Walt misusing a superpower
we don't know yet we don't we know he's
not using it here because he's such a
loser
what happened to Walter we want to know
no when we go to breakfast
there's the breakfast in the breakfast
and we meet his happily henpecked wife
what happens to a woman when the guy
she's with is a failure what does a
woman do usually if she's with the guy
what does she do well in this case
skylar over Mother's him she's trying to
do everything she can to help him out
she probably holds his hand where they
watch self-improvement videos at night
hoping he's gonna finally step up to the
plate but this is Walt's 50th birthday
by the way and they also get really
angry she's had affairs she's tried to
leave him but she can't she's tied to
the guy she's gonna be tied to him for
seven years
it says also his 50th birthday and she
gives him a plate full of soy bacon that
spells out 50 and he looks at it and
goes what is this stuff it's not real
and she says it's soy bacon you won't
taste the difference
everything about this scene shows us
what that he's a loser and she's trying
to not be panicked and disappointed at
what a loser he's turned out to be she's
also visibly pregnant so the bacon is
plastic the world is plastic and now
here comes their son Walt Jr who is
disabled that's not an accident
he comes into the room on his crutches
and he is a great kid but he's disabled
and when Skyler criticizes ring lady
says there's no hot water again and
Walter and Skyler look down at the table
because what why is it no hot water
everything in the scene is about how
it's disappointing and so she tells him
to eat the bacon eat the veggie bacon
now they go to the school even the car
he drives as a vomit green pomp Pontiac
Aztek the class disses him there's an
alpha male couple in there that won't
pay attention to his lecture we're still
in the B storyline which is can Walt
take care of his family that's the B
storyline question the answer is no he
cannot take care of his family
not at all this gorgeous couple makes
out in the back when he tells them to
stop they just did
him and then we see Walt go to his
second job which is working at a car
wash and not only is it working at a car
wash but his boss now tells him Walter
I'm short-handed today go out and do
wipe downs Walter now has to go from
behind the cash register to wiping down
the car and guess whose car he wipes
down that gorgeous alpha male couple
from the high school now they take
pictures of him laugh at him for being a
car cleaner and put them on Instagram oh
my god Walter White is washing cars whoa
why is being humiliated again and again
and again and it ends with a surprise
birthday party where we see is ultimate
humiliation but we also return to the a
storyline what is it Walt's
brother-in-law Hank who is a DEA agent
and by the way guys if you want to make
an antihero sympathetic surround him
with bigger a-holes than he is Hank is a
blowhard
who has made fun of Walt for years and
today he does the same thing he steals
Walt's beard he says well you got a
brain the size of Wisconsin we're not
gonna hold that against you haha come
here buddy
he drinks Walt's beer and shows his gun
to everybody right not subtle the kid
handles the gun Oh dad this is such a
big gun yeah it's a big gun and I give
it to man Walt's just the shrinking
little violet in the corner like he's
been for 15 years while Hank blurry
eights that's the way it's been that's
the way it's always gonna be but now we
return to the a story which is this on
the television why they all watch
there's Hank busting a drug dealer and
there's a pile of cash and Walt who's
been in the corner with his beer slumped
over every day why don't you come with
me on a ride-along buddy get some
excitement in your life and Walt says no
I can't do that
now we go back to the B storyline can
Walt take care of his family and in it's
his birthday so his wife tries to give
him a hand job and Walter can't get an
erection he can't take care of his
family he has no money his wife actually
stops in the middle of the to
celebrate the fact that she won of oz on
eBay and that's Walt's life tiny
disappointing awful and it's over for
him but now we end on the C story when
he goes to his carwash job and he's
looking at a beautiful girl in a
beautiful car that's the life he never
had he clutches his chest and he falls
to the ground that's our C storyline
which is is Walt gonna die that's how we
end the act on that cliffhanger now when
we open on the next act Walt's getting
the news he's going to die this is what
pushes him forward this is why we have
sympathy for him he's gonna die
but he's so disconnected from his own
life that he just tells the doctor
I heard yeah I'm gonna die near so when
you've gotten mustard on your collar
he goes home and now we're seeing him
reveal a new facet of himself we've
never seen he's a liar but now back at
the car wash when Bogdan orders him to
go out and do wipe downs again we're
seeing him change
he tells Bogdan to go screw himself
knocks everything off the counter and
leaves
Walter is changing but he's an addict
here now what is the definition of an
antihero an antihero is someone who
becomes evil for sympathetic reasons
this is why we like him this is Michael
Corleone II and the Godfather this is
Harvey Dent in in in Dark Knight we have
to have sympathetic reasons to like an
antihero
we have sympathy for Walt because we've
seen that he's gonna die now at the end
of the Act
he calls Hank and he says Hank can I
come on that right along can I see you
bust some drug dealers Walt is chained
and in act 3 we opened with Walt in the
back of Hank's car while Hank makes
racist jokes about the people who are
about to be busted then we see the eyes
busted and as we see Hank bust these
amphetamine dealers Walt looks out of
the car and he sees from the next house
over his former student Jesse jumping
out of a window and a naked woman
throwing his jeans this is the D
storyline amadee storyline here is will
Jesse and Walter become co-conspirators
and as we see Walter watch Jesse jump in
his car Walter comes on the license
plate and says captain crunch and he
thanks I am gonna follow Jesse around
Jesse flees the scene and that night
Walter shows up at Jesse's house and
says to him you and I are gonna cook
meth together and Jesse's like why are
you kidding me come on mr. white
even my high school teacher you don't
want to do that Walt says either that or
you go to prison cuz I turn you in that
is the new Walter that tough Walter that
Walter were gonna see through the entire
seven-year run of the show he is a
different guy and the D storyline
question will Walt and Jesse become
friends his answer it looks like they're
done it now we end the act not on that
but on a part where it makes the
audience stand up and Cheer Walt and
Skyler take their son to the mall to get
James and as they put these jeans on
their disabled son these three big jocks
start making fun of the Sun mummy my big
boy pants they're awful and Skyler sees
it and she wants Walt to do something
about these bullies but what does he do
he leaves the store like a wimp
forcing Skyler to start to say to the
son okay son I'm gonna go take care of
these guys but as she does Walt bursts
in the front of the store walks right up
to these three guys that are all three
feet taller than him and says come on
take your best shot
come on take your best shot get out of
here you stupid little twits and these
huge guys actually melt away
Walt's suddenly becoming a strong guy
and we're standing up and cheering him
even Skyler is shocked and a little
turned on because this is the new Walter
so we in the act with the B storyline
question Walt I care of his family
you bet he will he's tough he's new guys
is he gonna become a criminal yes but
the secret of great story is to make us
empathize with someone who's doing bad
things
Walt steps in now in act 4 we often have
a beginning we often have to store lines
together the a and the D this is often
true and it's true in this story the a
storyline remembers will won't become a
badass drug dealer and look at that when
we watch him and act for he's hustling
equipment out of his high school he's
become a thief beakers synthetic stuff
everything now we also are watching the
D story because Jesse is reluctantly
becoming the the Sorcerer's Apprentice
right that's exactly the relationship
they're gonna have for the next seven
years Jesse and Walter becoming
co-conspirators they're also we're also
seeing Walt's genius remember
superpowers being misused at the
beginning of the show when he's
beginning to use it he's beginning uses
chemical genius again we're gonna make a
product that is synthetically pure it's
gonna be perfect and Jesse's like now I
want to make chili Chili's my spec chili
P is my trademark we're gonna put chili
in it we are gonna make a synthetic
product that is perfect Jesse shut up so
this reluctant relationship really was
gonna go on for seven years the D
storyline will Walt ingest and become
colleagues is gonna resonate through the
entire seven years they'll fall apart
that come out together but at the very
last episode of this show they are still
co-conspirators right to the end the
other thing you're gonna see an act for
is this the most amazing use of the
suspense tools you've ever seen good
news bad news ticking clocks raising
stakes they are used brilliantly by
Gilligan it's part of the reason some
people can't watch this show for more
than ten minutes they have to out litter
turn it off and then cool down and watch
it again because the suspense is
agonizingly good and you're gonna see
all that in act 4
the other thing you're gonna see an act
for is that remember in a movie there is
what I call a see the four times in
a movie when the hero is asked to change
in a television show the hero's asked to
change to but he doesn't much and the
sense there's a five acts there's a B M
MOC for more information on this
structure go to university of story look
at my foundations lecture my TV lecture
this is a pattern that great television
shows have a knack for you're going to
see both the oh point the obstacle point
the moment when it looks like all is
lost and you're also gonna see the
climax of the television show where the
hero wins both of these points are
present in one act that's the brilliance
of using a structure of the ABCDE
storyline I know it sounds prissy and
mathematical but it's actually a
beautiful way to tell an original story
and make it entertaining you can tell
any story you want you can tell a story
about two skunks two bisexual skunks it
doesn't matter if you use these tools
actually I don't think about sexual
skunks worried work that well but
alright so anyway they get a used
Winnebago with all the money just that
Walter has in the world but when Walter
gets out of the credit union with the
cash and gives it to Jesse Jesse system
hey listen I got a known just for my own
because what you do affects me what you
do affects me have you just gone nuts it
doesn't compute why does a guy I don't
know sixty years old what is fifty how
does the six year old guy suddenly just
break bad I mean have you gone crazy
this affects me and Walter finally says
the critical thing about his core wound
remember his core wound is that I'm
powerless
that's his core wound and he says to
Jesse the truth right here he says I am
he's finally feeling powerful that's the
critical thing to realize about Walter
it is also his unsolvable dilemma
remember we talked about what that was
at the beginning of this lecture his
unsolved
well dilemma is that he wants to take
care of his family but the way he's
doing it is destroying his family that
is unresolvable it will never be
resolved not for seven years so Jessie
goes and gets the Winnebago we're still
in Act four they drive out to the desert
and they begin to make this meth
now most stories have what I call speed
and weed in a romantic comedy the weed
is real estate and alpha males and and
building shoe closets and having a guy
who can communicate and be sensitive as
well as powerful and strong it's the
pleasure you get from a story in this
story because the hook is how bad will
Walter go and the premises he's gonna
make drugs the weed and speed literally
is weed and speed as they make this drug
the music mounts watch this scene guys
you'll get caught up with it it's the
sorcerer and his assistant as they cook
this perfect meth and the music swells
and Jesse screws up and Walter saves him
and at the end there is a pan of
beautiful sky blue methamphetamine that
is the purest meth ever made in the
world and when it's finished you're the
goddamn Iron Chef you're amazing and
Walter says it's just basic chemistry
but thank you Jesse he is using his
genius for chemistry and he is becoming
a powerful guy still an app for Walter
says to Jesse how do we sell this and
Jesse says I know just the guy to take
it - and this is where the e plot kicks
in because the guy who was busted in the
second act crazy me Emilio and krazy-8
we cut to Jesse walking up to their
house a barking dog that's attacking a
dummy and we start to get danger rising
because when Jesse tries to sell this
drug to crazy eight crazy eight says hey
where'd you get this I know you didn't I
knew your little dumb ass didn't cook it
where'd you get this take me to this guy
we are approaching the all's lost moment
of the show because as their lowrider
neon yellow gangster car pulls up to the
Winnebago where Walter is standing in
his underwear with nobody for miles the
two gangsters pull their guns and they
prepare to kill Walter and Jesse that is
the low point for Walter now remember
what is this superpower how are we gonna
see it and remember what support what's
replaces character change in television
surprise because as they prepare to kill
them both ticking clocks guns Walter
says wait a minute
I'll teach you my recipe you let us live
I don't teach you how to cook and the
villains say okay now Walter hasn't been
saved it's only a temporary reprieve but
as he goes into the RV with both guys
guns pointed at his head ticking clocks
the gun when those guns go off the music
begins to give us a literal ticking
clock sound tick tock tick tock and as
we watch Walter create more
methamphetamine we see him pick up a
bottle that we've been explained is
poison if it's subjected to heat and
it's the clocks tick and one of the
villains throws a cigarette out the
window that's another ticking clock we
have four simultaneous to me clocks on
the scene watch it it's fabulous
suddenly Walter throws the red
phosphorus into the fire boom and a
poison blows up in the cloud and the two
gangsters begin to die Walter jumps out
of the RV slams a door behind him good
news bad news they fire through the door
but then they die Walt is winning the a
storyline will become a badass drug
dealer yes will Jesse and him work
together yes East storyline where Walt
and Jesse win over crazy and Emilio yes
but it could end here but it doesn't why
because we need more tension and
suspense suddenly that cigarette that
was thrown out the window catches fire
and the entire place starts to burn
wolf has to escape he gets in the RV as
the music swells he and Jessie roll
through the desert with those two bodies
in the back and guess what we're back at
the cold-open remember with the RV
running through the desert waltz
stopping getting out the two bodies in
the back he makes the video confession
he goes to the road he's got the gun
pointed and now that's where we are and
now we see that siren ticking clock get
louder and louder the cops are coming
Walt's gonna lose everything's over for
him then good news that turns out not to
be cops
but the firemen and they don't care
about Walt at all they go by flipping
his underwear up and down and he through
sheer amazing genius and luck has won
the firemen leave they've killed the two
guys Walt has answered the a storyline
question will you be a badass drug
dealer hell yes and I've become a
murderer too and then he vomits because
remember he's still a weak guy so in our
resolution we finally wrap up the final
storyline witches will Walt take care of
his family we see him laundering
literally the money that he's made he's
taking care of his family financially
and this time when he and Skyler go to
have sex she suddenly gasps because
Walter is that you he can suddenly be a
man there too so the story ends with
this B storyline answered yes with the a
storyline answered yes with the c-store
Lana answered yes every story that
answered yes Walt has become a badass
drug dealer and a murderer and we're
gonna watch him go further with that for
the next seven years this is brilliant
television because we've set up a hook
that we want to watch another hundred
episodes to see and it's a classic
classic thriller and guys television is
thirsty for thrillers there are 400
scripted stories now who need stories
please use the tools I've given you
tonight not only in thrillers but for
every television genre because they work
across the wall